hey youtubers it's Charlie, this is going to be my walking dead episode 6 video
all carol and daryl. Totally
explained what happened when he
came back to the church.
after the Abraham episode last week I
thought they might be jumping backwards
in time
we also found at work here was doing
between the time she left RIKEN season 4
in came back to save them I think the
most exciting thing though is the last
couple minutes basically explains what
but for now it's going to be quick
reminder to render the giveaway starts
now all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
careful first Bush me episode if you
haven't seen it yet starting with
top five moments number five carols
backstory
so just like abraham's episode last week
the upsurge up between present-day
in the past it bro carols backstory up
into small pieces
from right after she left brake crying
on the way down the road all the way up
to the minute that she saw the prison
fire
then family right after she rescued them
from terminus or help them escape
is really interesting in this episode
that she said I think that we don't get
to say people anymore
I'm not sure that she believes that I
think it's a situation where she cares
way too much about the people in the
church that's why she was trying to
leave when Darryl Carter
I think she's just so worried about them
that's why she was so quick to try and
kill Noah
by the end she totally come to our
senses to like they completely flipped
positions
Darrell wanted to leave no behind she
wanted to save them so
she's not too far gone despite being hit
by car I feel like that's a good PSA for
looking both ways before you cross the
street
seriously if you have a child just show
them that scene number four
surprise it snow on the run if you're
confused about the time line
he ran into their own bed for the first
time right after he escaped from the
hospital
couples tree observations during the
scene one probably never going to want
to go camping again
to never tried to steal darryl's
crossbow it will not end well
when Noah got caught under the bookcase
did anyone else get a flashback to Bob
in the grocery store but whatever the
liquor cased on top of them
it's almost like caramel was punishing
them for doing something really terrible
Carmen this case being Darrell such an
action hero dude moment when he lived at
cigarette
after taking his crossbow back imagine
what would happen if he tried to steal a
poncho to
der wanna push them out a window the
minute no appeared it was pretty clear
what the into the episode was going
be we knew carol was going to end up
captured in the hospital
and we knew daryl is going to be back at
the church with the mystery person
the big question was just how carol
ended up in the hospital
whether she did it on purpose or whether
was an accident are they capture
I guess you can consider getting hit by
a car to be halfway in between there
but she didn't do it on purpose but they
didn't capture
so many Everybody Hates Chris jokes in
here is not all bad
he has the information the Darrell in
the survivors will need to get Caroline
bet at a hospital
number three Debbie tmbn right over the
bridge no great PSA for wearing your
seatbelt
it's a new coal mine out to petition ANC
to make that car right over the bridge
party the EMC Walking Dead experienced
next year Comicon
I would totally sign a waiver for that
in a heartbeat such an awesome Thelma
and Louise moment for Caroline Darrell
the crash also duties at the Carroll
hurt storyline
like she's gonna need some sorta care if
you notice chasing her womb was
basically in the same place the bobs was
whenever he got bit like he got bit like
I think right around here
anytime any the main characters get like
really badly wounded on the show
you always wonder what's gonna happen is
like I don't think they're gonna die
but at some point they're gonna have to
deal with that giant gash
that as you want the conversations about
Abraham is still going on
like his hand wounded number two
comparing old Caroline dear old to the
new versions
it's been a long time since season one
soap hopefully
everyone has evolved as a character
sometimes people backslide
but it was awesome to hear carole sorta
recap her life as well as darryl's
he used to be a boy now he's a man
pretty simple
Carol little bit more complicated that
is why she's one of the more interesting
characters
the most messed up ones are always the
most interesting speaking a messed up
did you see the day Ross told that book
about childhood abuse
that's a nice call back to the episode
with Beth where he talked about his
childhood
I think it was implied in that episode I
think we can have understood that his
parents abused him or his dad did
I can to see everyone crying if we find
him reading it later poor little Darrell
if the same story with Carol they're
both victims of abuse
thing about what Carroll said though the
care that she used to be just kept
getting burnt away
the original care like season one Carol
preseason want carol was sophia
who diz went back to her husband
ed in kept getting abused she was burned
to wake cut to the prison
she gets to be like a normal person
someone she thought she could be
things go sideways dad Carol gets burned
away in now
she's just not sure who she is she's
like almost two fried she has to find a
way to evolve or die
matter has to stay to the existence
growth and decay
or in this case growth or Walker fingers
crossed that this version of Carol does
not literally get bird
away in the finale and my number one WTF
moment of course care gets taken to the
hospital
indira forms a plan I don't think the
police officers intentionally hit her
I think they're just going really fast
that is why you must always look both
ways before crossing the street
especially if you're on a television
show so fast forward to next week
what's going to be happening now just
like last year by going to be a two-part
finale
so part 1 will be the attack part 2 will
be the resolution
they have a lot of people in a lotta
guns so do we
defected be showed abraham's group in
that teaser 2 is kind of interesting
right now they either have to turn
around and come back or
they have to move on to DC last year to
the midseason finale
everyone was split in all different
directions I don't think you're going to
do the exact same thing
that's why I think their group is going
to continue on to DC option B though
is that they could run into the
survivors and help out during the finale
just to talk about the biggest rumors
I've seen so far 1 is that
Carol dies sacrifices up from Bath the
other big rumor
tibet dies obviously both rumors talking
about someone being dying
haven't seen any spoilers so you have to
worry about that but
I think the walking dead has finished
filming the last half for the season
release they've had the wrap party I'm
not quite sure how far had the film but
I think that they're done with all 16
episodes at this point
because using the start filming in the
summer the really fun thing
underlining you guys don't celebrate
Thanksgiving cuz your international
countries but
here in America we have like a big
Thanksgiving holiday
Walking Dead is like right after that so
I am very thankful for that
in advance so is totally subtext but I
have to address
Carol and Daryl address that ship in
this episode
the minute they landed in that bed
together I saw so many pictures post on
Twitter
if you look if you want them together
this is the closest you're ever gonna
get
like they're never going to consummate
that relationship
The Walking Dead is not a hopeful show
it is a tragedy
they just call it The Walking tragedy
pellets and kinda pessimistic but I feel
like the characters just do not get a
happy ending
yeah if you could live long enough
eventually the walkers will die out but
it's not a hopeful show although they're
hopeful moments
let me know that what was your favorite
moment from the episode and what do you
think that their plan of attack is going
to be whenever they come back to try and
get that thing Carol out
I feel like it's gonna be a reverse
virgin above what terminus was
like they left terminus after creating
this big explosion
I feel like they're gonna create some
sort a big explosion and then run in
although Rick in the teaser talk a
little bit about getting to my surprise
really like the options are infiltration
Mike really stop the infiltration
or just smashing grab overall though you
the answer to saudade
totally love Caroline Dale to the most
interesting characters in the show
the course the episode that focuses on
them would be one of the best ones in
the season
they also have the benefit being the
episode right before the lead up to the
finale
board the finale itself considered a
two-part finale there's no way that
episode is going to be a downer
just in general I feel like the den a
much better job in season five
building the tension with each episode
season 4 part 1
felt like such a dead zone in terms of
action Petersburg quite sitting on the
edge of your seat
whenever we got to the governor's attack
on the prison I mean yeah I was a holy
shit moment
but if you like we're gonna blind sided
with it this season is a little bit like
that van ride
over the bridge teetering on the edge
and you know what's going to happen but
you know it's gonna fall
seizures wince and wait for it to happen
let's all hope that the characters limp
away at the end is like allendale
there's always the question about
whether or not the walking dead: knees
to kill of characters
this article herschel off because he
felt like such a safety net
a good place have safety for the
survivors at the prison
the writers course wanna take that
safety way from into the Herschel out
from right underneath them
I do kinda see carol is that can occur
to right now and she feels almost
invincible
so far the people that could I during
the finale I feel like she's at the top
of the list
it's like the more powerful you are the
bigger target you are in the writers
room
so some things look forward to next week
big Carl episode
looks like he's going to try and force a
weapon in the gables and don't think
it's going to go well
also during the episode there was a
commercial
at the Morgan scene from season 1 I feel
like that's foreshadowing that he's
gonna show up in the mid season finale
at some point
could be episode 7 could be episode 8
but I definitely think he's gonna show
up somewhere
if you remember but the last time we saw
him he was armed
to the T just a clear sign that shit is
gonna go down
be sure to subscribe to get my video
posted right after the episode airs next
week
in the meantime you can click here for
the CUNY video I the annotation is as a
person tomorrow
and you can click here for me episode by
video thank you so much watching Flight
of high five and say a prayer for Carol